which recognizes the transfer interceptor of both humans
and NHPs to cross the blood-brain barrier in vivo.
Thank you, Andrew.
Thank you.
All right.
My name is Andrew Dunn.
I'm from Shape Therapeutics.
Thank you for attending this talk.
And let's get started.
All right.
There we go.
Maybe.
OK.
Forward-looking statements and all that.
So at Shape Therapeutics, one of the main pillars
of the company is on capsid development.
So I've been working over the last few years
to develop CNS targeting capsids following systemic
administration.
And our platform uses AAV5.
And so we employ direct mutagenesis
rather than loop insertion.
And so we directly mutate capsids of loop 8.
And these are around the residues
that were previously identified by the McKinnigroup
to interact with sialic acid.
Under the theory that you could probably,
if you mutate these regions, retarget from sialic acid
to another receptor that hopefully is of interest
and benefit to your program.
So using this method, we previously reported on a capsid
that we call DB1, or deep brain 1.
And then with a relatively moderate dose of 1E13 viral
genomes per kilogram, the cinemologous macaque,
we were able to use and deliver our RNA fix payload
and achieve fairly significant on target editing
of our target transcript for our Parkinson's disease program,
specifically in deep brain structures of interest to us,
like the substantia nigra.
So now that you have a fairly interesting biologic
that you want to take forward before deploying
copious amounts of capital on clinical trials,
it's probably helpful to ask the question
whether or not it might work in humans.
And so to that end, it's important to know
what the primary receptor is that is mediating your capsid.
So over the last year, I've been onboarding and optimizing
an LCMS technique to try to identify
the target of these novel capsids.
And so again, these capsids, they were mutated randomly,
so we did not start a priori with a particular target in mind.
And so this is just a simple technique.
You grind up your tissue, extract your protein,
add your AAV, as bait, pull down your AAV, purify the protein,
send it off for LCMS, and then try
to identify the target from the soup that comes out.
And LCMS is a very powerful technique.
It's very sensitive, but it can also be very dirty.
And so you achieve a lot of hits.
Now, this is an interaction assay.
It's not a functional assay, so you
don't know if any of these hits are actually
allowing for an enhanced functional transduction
when expressed.
So we identified hundreds of candidates,
then filtered those down rationally
based upon what might act as a receptor,
to have a transmembrane domain as a GPI anchored.
And over all of these hits, where we then
delivered a luciferase transgene in vitro,
we cloned all of these hits individually
and expressed them across text and chose,
and then delivered DB1, transduced to DB1,
transduced with another shape capsid,
CNS tropic shape capsid, as well as wild type 5.
And there was one receptor at the very last plate
that we ran that provided significant enhancement
of functional transduction in vitro
that was specific and that was unique to DB1,
and that was transferrin receptor.
And so with that in mind, or with that in hand,
you can start to ask the question,
does it have really any chance to work in humans?
If we think that transferrin receptor is the primary
receptor that is mediating our method of action
and crossing the blood-brain barrier,
does it interact with the human orthologs?
So from previous studies, that we know that DB1 works
fairly well in Old World monkeys in African green
and in Sinemologous macaques,
but we also know that it doesn't work in mice.
And so then we can ask the question pretty easily,
will it work in humans?
Do we think, does it have a chance of working in humans?
And so we ran an ortholog screen,
where you can just take all the different orthologs
of transferrin receptor and then express them
individually in cell lines and then see
what the functional transduction is
when you overexpress those receptors.
And pretty obviously, unfortunately for DB1,
that it did not appear to functionally interact
with the human ortholog.
We had excellent maintenance across the Old World monkeys,
but we did not have a functional transduction boost
when overexpressing the human ortholog.
So then we wanted to ask the question,
where on what location of transferrin receptor
might the DB1 be interacting with?
And so we made this assumption or this hypothesis
that it might be interacting
with the apical domain of transferrin receptor.
So if you run an alignment of Sinemologous transferrin
receptor with human transferrin receptor,
you can start to see in the apical domain
a couple of locations of divergent amino acids.
And so when you start to look at a structure
of transferrin receptor,
these divergent amino acids actually exist
around the tops of loops,
the loop that might be interacting
with a capsidum interest.
So we broke these up into blocks, one, two, three and four.
Each block either contains one
or a few divergent amino acids.
Then you can start to create a chimera
where you take the Sinemologous ortholog,
that block from Sinnoh,
graph that onto the human ortholog
and start to see if that block
might rescue functional transduction.
So that's what we did.
So we have the full human or the human apical domain
and then grafting the full Sinnoh onto the human ortholog
as well as each of the blocks individually
where we take the block from the Sinemologous ortholog
onto the human ortholog.
And there was one block from all of these four blocks
that rescued functional transduction of DB1
when overexpressing that human Sinocamera
and that was block A.
What's nice about block A
is there is a single divergent amino acid
when comparing Sinnohs to humans.
And that is that position 208.
It is a glycine in the Sinemologous macaques
and it is an arginine in humans.
That is one of the most divergent pairs
of amino acids that you can get.
So the fun continues for us.
So we wanted to try to jump the speciation barrier.
To do that, we ran single and double site saturated
mutagenesis of DB1 to see if we could cross over
and hopefully bridge from Sinnohs into humans.
See if we can get something that works on both.
And panning in vitro where we express individually
either the human transfer and receptor overexpressing
human transfer and receptor overexpressing.
Expressing the Sinemologous ortholog
relative to the parental cell line,
the unedited cell line.
So we were able to identify a population
that appeared to gain this function against.